[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
en esta edición especial desde la feria
de Internacional del Libro de Bogotá en
nuestro Stand de France 24 hasta el que
ha venido Paco Ignacio taibo 2 a
visitarnos es activista historiador
escritor mexicano nacido en España
Muchas gracias Paco por estar en la
entrevista de
usted es el director del Fondo de
Cultura económica y de sus novelas
negras uno de sus grandes personajes el
detective de lascuran vivía un poco con
el mantra de renovarse o Morir Ese ha
sido su papel en el mundo editorial no
fue algo más divertido fue la llegada de
un gobierno diferente de izquierda a
México y la propuesta de vamos a
convertirnos en una editorial popular no
Solo lo que ya era el fondo 80 años de
cobertura de libros académicos sino más
allá crear no solo nuevas colecciones
buscando lectores que no tienen acceso
habitualmente tanto jóvenes como adultos
mayores y en paralelo bajar el precio de
los libros y en paralelo crear nuevas
redes de distribución que llegaran hasta
el último pueblo perdido en las montañas
mexicanas Entonces el fondo fue un reto
más que de renovarse o Morir fue un reto
de empezar a vivir de otra manera Y
estos cuatro años han sido muy buenos en
cuanto que los resultados se sienten ya
en México entre las iniciativas destacan
también los clubes de lectura populares
es porque cree usted que es importante
socializar un acto tan individual como
la lectura es que la lectura nunca fue
un acto individual parece individual
pero 30 segundos después de haber leído
una gran novela que urge decirle a
alguien Acabo de leer una gran novela y
rompes
la individualidad es cierto el primer
contacto es cara a cara con el escritor
pero el segundo contacto Es compartir y
los clubs de lectura lo que hacen Es
compartir Pero además estimular hemos
crecido en México de una manera
sorprendente en estos años Hemos llegado
a 12.000 clubs de lectura en todo el
país en comunidades donde nunca había
habido algo parecido de todo tipo y cada
Club genera debate genera pensamiento
crítico genera modelos
tú como quién quieres ser cuando seas
grande como la mamá de gengis Khan o
como el Che Guevara que esto esto baje
construyendo un espacio de estímulo a la
lectura popular y muy amplio El problema
es que para mantenerlo tenemos que sacar
seis millones de libros de regalo al año
para estimular todo este mundo
Esto va en contra corriente también de
esta industria de entretenimiento
cultural cada vez más fragmentada
incluso dicen que los adolescentes se
aburren viendo fútbol Cómo competir
también contra el tiktok solo no no hay
que competir hay que usar el tiktok lo
hago tiktoks de vez en cuando y Leo
mangas no me quiere conflicto otras
formas de diversión son paralelas la
única clave es que tienes que llegar al
mundo adolescente diciendo esta novela
te va a volar las neuronas compadre y
tienes que decirles leer es muy
divertido leer es apasionante leer
subversivo y tienes que llegar con
mensajes a veces muy rasposos como no no
aceptes recomendaciones de maestros ni
de padres lee lo que te dé la gana y
solo así vas a lograr recuperar la
posibilidad de lectura adolescente que
está muy muy debilitada en todo el mundo
es una forma también de recurrir a
tiktok etcétera de luchar contra moral
más bien de establecer una superioridad
moral y decir leer No solo es divertido
leer
transformar leer cambia y es apasionante
es darle a la literatura lo que los que
leemos sabemos que tiene contárselo a
los que no lo saben
usted acaba de publicar la libertad 13
historias para la historia es un
recopilatorio de distintos personajes
que marcaron la historia del siglo XX
recurrir a ese Siglo XX También sirve
para entender este siglo XXI en el que
estamos ahora sí yo quería es un libro
que tiene dos intenciones una recuperar
personajes e historias sorprendentes
entre ellas una francesa que es la
historia de un espía de la comuna que me
desconcertó cuando descubrí que tenía 17
casos en París y mi pregunta era era
casateniente o espía entonces me metí
una pequeña investigación pero la clave
del libro es decir hay maneras
diferentes de contar la historia
planteándote en la narrativa
aprovechando la narrativa Y entonces el
libro es una muestra cada uno de los
trabajos es diferente de
y para mí Por qué escogí ese personaje
ese momento por arbitrario y porque me
parecía muy divertido hay un capítulo
dedicado y fundador del Photoshop sí o
un capítulo dedicado a explicar Por qué
las galeras venecianas en lepanto llevan
un gallardete de un león al lado que es
asirio entonces narrar la historia
demostraba que puedes llegar a grandes
públicos contando sin perder profundidad
pero ganando calidad narrativa y son más
aburridos los personajes hoy que
entonces que no son más aburridos los
que los cuentan
estamos plagados de académicos e
historiadores y especialistas que
aburren a su madre y la pueden matar de
aburrimiento porque su manera de contar
Está encerrada en el círculo de La
Academia en el del especialista y no a
cambio eso y algunos narradores hoy en
Europa
historiadores historiadores narradores
que están rompiendo el esquema y
diciendo no no Espera A qué rigor pero
también hay pasión y placer
usted además de estos personajes que nos
contaba de su nuevo libro también se ha
adentrado en biografías como del Che
Guevara o Pancho Villa es en este bueno
en el futuro de este siglo habrá otro
tipo de personajes por ejemplo el otro
día usted estuvo en la inauguración con
Francia Márquez una mujer negra que
ahora vicepresidenta de Colombia
cambiarán también ese tipo de personajes
que nos resultan interesantes cada época
tienen sus personajes no nos preocupemos
démosles tiempo para que crezcan alguno
en particular te interesa de este
momento no No suelo escribir sobre
personajes vivos Hay que darles tiempo
porque se vuelvan personajes históricos
el pasado siempre es más interesante que
el presente No necesariamente pero es
diferente
cuando trabajas con el presente tienes
que ser periodismo y yo lo hago de vez
en cuando cuando trabajas con el pasado
puedes hacer historias narrativa
el género es el que te permite
aproximaciones diferentes al material
que tienes enfrente
escribió con uno vivo que es el
subcomandante Marcos los muertos
incómodos Cómo ven el panorama global es
utopía zapatista de un mundo donde
queparse a Marcos
yo lo conté desde afuera el libro que
escribimos juntos era un libro desde dos
mundos que se reunían en la novela
Entonces si quieres una perspectiva
zapatista se la vas a tener que pedir a
Marcos yo tengo una perspectiva urbana
mexicana y cierto popular y muy
latinoamericana pero lamentablemente
para mí no tengo una perspectiva de las
selvas de Chiapas Y cuál es esa
perspectiva de la que nos habla la suya
la mía es que urge que lancemos una
campaña a nivel de toda la América
hispanoparlante para democratizar la
lectura y romper las trabas económicas
distributivas
neoliberales mercantiles que hacen del
mundo del libro un mundo donde manda el
dinero y la moda
en este sentido Por ejemplo en Francia y
como el precio único u otras medidas
también de cargar con más impuestos a
las plataformas digitales para defender
a las librerías
no lo que hay que hacer es construir
desde abajo y en Francia Hay un montón
de experiencias de construcción desde
abajo yo participo en varias
con grupos de lectores y de hecho
Público de una manera muy rara en
Francia lo mismo en grandes editoriales
como Rivas payó que en editoriales
chiquitas anarquistas
me gusta moverme como el pez en el agua
usted hace poco dijo que le gustaría
vivir a un 20 años más Que le mueve la
curiosidad
No dije Exactamente eso dije necesito
vivir 20 años más para poder escribir
todo lo que tengo empezado poder
terminar los libros que tengo empezados
y que se Cómo alimenta esa curiosidad
bien me obliga a varias cosas
una que tengo historias que quiero
contar y que todavía no me da tiempo a
terminarlas segunda Necesito hacer un
pacto con los jóvenes para que empujen
mi sigue de rueda en las manifestaciones
en primera línea hasta el final y luego
soy de izquierda desde que tengo cinco
años cinco años voy a renunciar ahora
que tengo 74 No
ya vamos a ir concluyendo hay una
pregunta que me parece pertinente
hacerle cree que usted va a publicar un
día una novela escrita por Inteligencia
artificial para qué
la Inteligencia artificial la traigo
interconstruida yo soy mi propio disco
duro pero viendo las dinámicas que hay
actualmente de que atemorizan incluso a
nosotros los periodistas de que podemos
perder nuestro trabajo si perdemos
nuestro trabajo como periodistas porque
lo estábamos haciendo muy mal no te
inquietes y no es el sueño comunista
tener que dejar de trabajar para que las
máquinas hagan creo que es el sueño
equivocado el sueño correcto y en eso
estaba ahora en un debate con melón
sobre dejar de trabajar trabajar menos
horas Yo decía sí y no Y la parte del no
es convertir trabajo en algo creativo
placentero divertido apasionante hay un
doble juego
que no solo tiene que ver con disminuir
las horas de trabajo sino volver el
trabajo algo creativo y no destructivo y
no rutinario y todavía cree que las
máquinas no van a llegar a tener ni la
inventiva ni la creatividad una máquina
no va a poder escribir todavía 100 años
de soledad por ejemplo y bueno si le
escribe bendita sea la máquina le
pondremos nombre la llamemos la
Gabrielito
no Hay que tenerle miedo a la tecnología
a cada rato aparece un fantasma se acabó
la historia se acabó la novela las
máquinas vienen
déjate de historias
el la novela es la madre de todas las
guerras y se construye de abajo hacia
arriba y es un fenómeno de creación cada
vez más complejo no no
los pronosticadores de los futuros
horribles no cuentan conmigo para
apoyarlos así que vamos aún con la
última etapa de las novelas sí que es
una novela más corta más fragmentada
como hablábamos antes esas grandes obras
son más difíciles también por los ritmos
de la sociedad por todos esos estímulos
yo no sé tú pero yo cuando encuentro una
novela que me gusta me gusta que sea
gorda
y cuando leí Juego de tronos Me
encantaba que tuviera siete tomos
también es cierto que de vez en cuando
pido la brevedad y el fulgor de una
novela corta
no creo que haya receta
cada libro pide su tamaño a veces estás
leyendo a este libro le sobran 100
páginas pero a veces estás leyendo este
libro le faltan 50 páginas
lo importante siempre Serán las
historias
y encontrar la manera
como empatizas con ellas
se nos acaba el tiempo Paco Muchas
gracias por haber estado aquí a
visitarnos
un placer Pueden seguir más contenidos
como este en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]